far from building bridges china has been
increasingly threatening its neighbor
with its military the numbers of chinese
air force incursions into taiwan's air
defense zone have gone up as has the
rhetoric from beijing china views taiwan
as a renegade province that needs to be
reunited with the mainland now this has
forced taiwan to double down on
modernizing its own military more on
that in a moment but first a look at how
some members of taiwan's elite
amphibious reconnaissance and patrol
unit the arp are being tested to see if
they are good enough to join the marine
corps elite force of frogmen
[Music]
this is the final exercise of a brutal
training course
the marines call it the road to heaven
getting over the line is not to be taken
for granted
more than half of the 31 candidates
failed to finish
this 26 year old graduate says he knows
what it takes to succeed
the first three days are very exhausting
but during the last few days it gets
better after your body gets used to it
but of course you have to rely on your
willpower and determination
the training is designed to test the
stamina of the marines
and to eliminate those unable to
withstand the pressure
all of those taking part have
volunteered to do so
some out of a feeling of patriotism
others are keen to push themselves to
their limits
exercises include spending hours in the
water
after having had very little food or
sleep for days
the main reason for being so harsh to
them is to train their willpower because
our unit belongs to the special forces
so in times of war we need to have
stronger willpower and better physical
abilities than other units
the frogmen of the elite force are among
those who would be deployed in the event
of any conflict with china
which has been increasing military
pressure on taiwan of late
they would be expected to scout enemy
locations and call in attacks
for such tasks the trainers say the men
need to be able to cope with the
harshest of conditions
and joining me now for more is wendy
sung he's a lecturer in taiwan studies
at australia's anu college of asia and
the pacific and he joins me now from
taipei mr sung how real is the fear of a
chinese invasion or attack in taiwan
well uh i think
while people do take the possibility of
a military confrontation with china
seriously
i think over time people have been
simply living under the possibility or
the shadow of a chinese military
confrontation scenario for
easily over a quarter century by now
so i think over time people just begin
to try to tune it out and live their
lives for the most part
and i think for the general public
that's the that's the sense
they have obviously for the government
leaders and those who are in the
military they do uh they are being a lot
more proactive in terms of finding out
ways to improve the capacity and
mitigate the risk of confrontation with
china speaking of the response
militarily i mean we look at military
modernization that taiwan is undertaking
i wonder if that is the cornerstone of
taiwan's strategy to counter the threat
from china
yes i mean i think taiwan's strategy
towards managing military uh threat from
china are essentially two-pronged you
can talk about it in terms of military
modernization of taiwan's forces itself
as well as more international and
diplomatic endeavors
so just to talk about i think the first
point taiwan's own autonomous military
capacity
taiwan obviously knows that china is
easily like 50 60 times bigger than
itself in population terms
so taiwan is not going to try to
outspend china dollar for dollar in
terms of military procurement
instead what taiwan tries to do
is to find ways that you can cultivate
niche capacities so we talk about for
example this thing called asymmetric
warfare ability where taiwan has tried
to increase things like missile
launchers more defensive
ballistic missile defense systems
sea mines and other ways like that where
taiwan can kind of get defensive
capacity on the cheap
and
in addition to that as well
there is something to be said about
finding ways to boost taiwan's own
reserve forces and just at the end of
last year taiwan was going ahead
in terms of
doing reform to its reform reserve
forces structure so as to sort of park
part of that mutual capacity in the
civilian everyday economy so as to keep
it more sustainable
now defense minister tuko chang last
year said in october that tensions with
china are at their worst in four decades
does taipei see these getting worse this
year
well taipei certainly believes that
there's a lot more need to take it even
more seriously than it has to you know
you had in the past
i'll say that in terms of actual degree
of threat assessment
taiwan is largely alert but are not
alarmed at the moment
the primary reason being that in order
for china to launch a successful
invasion of taiwan
china still has a long way to go in
terms of developing the amphibious
landing capacity and transportation
capacity across the taiwan strait before
a actual occupation could happen
so in that
front taiwan is still
relatively confident that is able to
hold up a chinese offenses
but meanwhile all these intensification
of military planes uh chinese warplane
near taiwan strait do create greater
risk of escalation as was accidental
escalation when things would get out of
control
we'll leave it there for the time being
thank you so much for joining us today
venti song from the anu college of asia
in the pacific thank you so much